you joe biden
is pushing to raise the federal minimum
wage to 15
an hour that may help some of the people
who get raised wages
it will definitely hurt others according
to congressional budget office a 15
minimum wage will eliminate almost a
million and a half jobs and increase the
federal deficit
dramatically neil patel has thought a
lot about this topic he wrote a column
about it for the boston herald he's the
publisher of the daily caller he joins
us tonight
to assess you know thanks a lot for
coming on so
economic arguments aside it does seem
like the minimum wage is
is popular in general with the public
and this is likely to happen given who
controls congress
given that what's the wise way do you
think to raise the minimum wage
tucker uh thanks for having me if you're
going to have a minimum wage
it doesn't make any sense to have it the
same in every location in america
it costs more than twice as much to live
in manhattan as it does in a small town
in kansas
and there's there's no earthly reason
both those places should have the same
minimum wage
similarly it doesn't make any sense to
have the same minimum wage for huge
multinational companies with thousands
of employees
and billions of dollars in profits as it
does for say the deli on the corner uh
of your block at home the deli owner is
probably working in his own store he may
want a few
hours off in the afternoon and bring in
a high school kid
the concept of the left's concept of a
livable wage
i think it's much easier to apply that
to a walmart or a target
uh than it is to the delhi guy and yet
we don't
we have one minimum wage applying in
every place for every business it makes
zero sense
could have something to do with who
donates to which political party i mean
it seems like some of these big
businesses would actually be in favor of
a higher minimum wage if they thought it
would drive their competitors out of
business
so the huge multinational companies that
dominate washington
and these policy debates are actually
mostly for the minimum wage increase
uh the retailers the big retailers like
target walmart amazon
they're definitely in for it they're
publicly in favor of it
and it's because it crushes their small
business competitors
they can afford it they're already
mostly paying a 15 an hour wage
uh and they know that the the ones they
compete with these small town businesses
can't afford it
so uh that's another reason why you know
why doesn't washington call their bluff
how about 20 or more
on huge multinationals but 10 or less on
the
small business in the corner i mean
this is pretty much the last thing after
a year of covet and riots
that small businesses need right now is
it not
it's the last thing small businesses
need it's the last thing our country
needs i don't know if you saw the stats
today
60 percent of the people involved in the
capitol hill riots had gone through
extreme economic hardship recently
meaning bankruptcies
massive credit layoffs so the problems
we're having in our economy especially
in the small business sector where small
businesses just lost 30 percent of the
revenue this year and
30 percent of all small businesses just
closed down
washington needs to start looking at
this and coming up with more innovative
policies
than ones that only are aligned with the
big business agenda
that's such a smart point that i've
heard from nobody else 30
minimum wage for amazon warehouse
workers
no minimum wage for the dry cleaner on
your block i love that
neil patel i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you